[Music]
well I want to welcome all of the
players to St Louis also referred to as
the chess capital of the nation this was
always my favorite time of the year when
we have the best players in America
playing
[Music]
chess the St Louis chess club has hosted
the last 15 US championships elevating
The Prestige of these Premier Events and
you the players are the best us chess
has to offer and we're proud to see you
here over the next two weeks we
celebrate that us chess and the St Louis
chess club do what we do best we are
committed to creating a welcoming and
safe environment for all be they one of
the top players or the Casual chess fan
since the Championships came to St Louis
in 2009 we've learned more than anything
we want what is best for the game and
for the people who make up our chess
community and I'm proud that us chess is
able to partner with the St Louis chess
club as leaders in the Chess World now
on behalf of the chess club and the
board of directors the St Louis Club
remains committed to our mission of
creating a worldclass venue for players
from across the globe to enjoy and we
will do everything in our power to
continue to make the tangible meaningful
changes that Foster an equitable
environment and help the St Louis Club
be the safe and best place in the world
to play chess thank
[Music]
you